it's lazy
it just doesn't work it's making me a
little bit angry
i'm i'm done yeah yeah thank you
[Music]
what happened to you i thought you were
at robert's lake house well when you
break up with someone it's not really
very fun to go swimming with them
anymore
they broke up he dumped you why is that
the assumption here
what do you have in your hand oh my god
i'm engaged
well that's good because your mother and
i are separating
[Music]
i would just like to get out of here
it's our mom i thought he was dead he
just fired his last assistant
now he needs someone to paint a barn
using only the color yellow
okay that's fine norway
norway actual norway
mr hourman i'm so happy to meet you it's
so beautiful it's almost like
a bad painting it looks like a painting
that you would make
not you but certainly not you at all but
if you tried to make a painting of it it
would almost be like
cheesy this is yours
[Music]
it's amazing to be your apprentice so do
not use the word amazing okay
this is just hard work you're gonna hate
it
of course
what the viking museum this is holder he
plays the chief
i am the chief where are you from
cincinnati
[Music]
[Applause]
oh i see the two of you have met he's
here because he understands the real
value of a viking funeral for his father
go tell my son i am here listen your
mother
ben speak gangulari
what happened
right now
[Applause]
[Music]
what is this here jiren
gosh it really is
you